is on the program mrs howard as always
good good to have you on and of course a
huge amount for us to talk about this
morning nothing least
at not least of course than that at that
trial uh that is being launched today
just tell us a little bit about it
yeah absolutely so uh the uh
oxford trial is looking at um
how um as has been done in the past with
hepatitis
and of course with polio and measles
mumps and
rubella for children you can look at
mixing uh vaccines and see the impact at
four weeks
and at 12 weeks uh it's an important
trial we're supporting it through the
vaccines task force with seven million
pounds um it will report probably
after the summer and of course it will
have no impact on the deployment which
i'm sure your viewers
will want to hear and so if you're
currently
had the fisa biontech vaccine you will
get your fisa biontech vaccine is your
second
dose the boosted dose and of course if
you have the oxford astrozenica vaccine
you'll get the osteoarthritic vaccine
this is more longer term uh keep
keeping us ahead of the uh or at least
in the leadership position i should say
in the world
in helping the whole world because no
one is safe until we're all safe and
uh if we understand and more about how
we can
use vaccines together uh then we should
be in a much stronger position
in terms of vaccinating the united
kingdom but also the rest of the world
and we await the results of the trial uh
then with with great interest i wonder
if we can focus on one of the vaccines
which is
which is currently being deployed at the
fisa vaccine
a number of people have got in touch
because of some concerns over research
that has been produced in a variety of
places it appears in fact we've got a
number of pieces of research some
suggesting
that there isn't sufficient uh
protection given by just one dose
another piece of research this morning
suggesting that by 21 days after the
first dose
you perhaps enjoyed 90 protection can
you just provide a little bit of
reassurance
to those who have only had one dose of
the fisa vaccine
that there is sufficient efficacy in
just that
absolutely um the mhra our regulator
uh one of the best regulators in the
world and of course the joint committee
on vaccination and immunization and our
chief medical
officers of england scotland wales and
northern ireland have looked at this
and looked at the data and actually
after
15 to 21 days
the single first dose of visor gives
a very high protection of course the
second base then gives you that boost
and that longevity as well and that data
has been
examined thoroughly by all those
different
uh the regulator the joint committee and
of course the chief medical officer
and their recommendation of the 12-week
dosing interval is the right one and
it's what we
will deliver in this vaccination
deployment program the largest
vaccination deployment program
in the history of the nhs very quickly
if we can
just a question on the oxford um vaccine
it's been reported today that they are
already
tweaking the vaccine to deal with the
new perhaps
worrying variants that that are
circulating in the uk at the moment
can you confirm that maybe give us an
idea just roughly of when we might have
that updated vaccine
uh coming up to speed yeah absolutely
neil so
it's very unlikely that the current
vaccines won't be
effective on uh the variance whether the
cancer
other variants especially when it comes
to severe illness and hospitalization so
that is
the good news which is why we're
absolutely moving as fast as we can
to get to that mid-february target of
protecting the top four
cohorts that's 15 million people in the
united kingdom
but all manufacturers fisa biontech
moderna of course oxford astrazeneca
and others are looking at how they can
improve their vaccine
to make sure that we are ready for any
variant there are about 4 000 variants
around the world
of cobalt now we are the largest um
genome sequencing industry we're about
50 of the world genome industry
genome sequencing industry and we're
keeping a library of all the variants
that we're ready to be able to respond
uh whether in the autumn or beyond to
any
uh challenge that the virus may present
and produce the next vaccine
so that we can always protect the united
kingdom and of course offer it to the
rest of the world as well
minister can we be be accurate as to
when we might get a date for the the
hotel quarantine scheme
being up and running there was a
suggestion we might get some form of
announcement from the health secretary
today
that appears to have gone away so
the hotel quarantine is one part of our
border policy of course you know that
people now are required to have
pre-departure testing otherwise they'll
be turned away they have to fill in a
passenger locator form
otherwise they'll be turned away and of
course they have to quarantine
for 10 days which is being enforced much
more strictly including
fires being issued by the police and
much greater police presence at ports
and airports people have to
actually say why they are uh traveling
and travel is restricted only to
essential
uh travel but the quarantine
hotel is being operationalized and that
will play a
you know part of this overall strategy
and the secretary of state for health
next week will be setting out
the operational elements of that policy
as other countries have done you know
germany changed their
their border policy in january as did
canada when these new variants were
appearing and of course we did as well
to strengthen it and make it more robust
and we continue to do so hotel
quarantine next week
so so next week but we understand that
the necessity for it to come on
a as soon as possible it's a separate
system of course but dido harding giving
evidence yesterday
suggested that as many as 20 000 people
who should be
self-isolating under test and tracer
are not doing so given that the system
at the moment is
you know self-isolate if you arrive here
from
from overseas but not in a monitored
hotel
how can we be sure that there isn't a
similar level of non-compliance amongst
international travelers
well first of all um we have restricted
international travel
from those countries where we're worried
about the variant whether it's brazil or
portugal or south africa and we
acted immediately grant shaps the social
state of transport
acted immediately on that but if you are
arriving you have to quarantine
from countries where you are allowed to
come to the united kingdom for 10 days
and we are absolutely using you know
passenger locator forms to know exactly
where you are
but i suppose i suppose the point is
though minister if the system was
working there would be no need for us to
have quarantine hotels
well it's an additional safeguard and
it's right because we've seen other
countries
actually implement it and implement it
well and we think it's the right thing
to do
which is why we're adding it to the uh
you know other
measures that we're taking to make sure
that our borders remain
safe and robust as we vaccinate the
nation
and protect obviously the most
vulnerable so it's in addition to that
it's not the whole of the border policy
sure
can we just have a little bit of clarity
what are the tests
that the government will be applying to
decide whether or not we should move
out of lockdown so as the prime minister
set out yesterday at the press
conference
on the 22nd of february when parliament
returns we'll put
uh two parliament our roadmap of first
opening schools on the 8th of march
so if you work to the date i've just
talked to you about neil which is the
mid-february target
of vaccinating the most vulnerable top
four cohorts
in that phase one so phase one goes down
to nine cohorts
and we'll continue after the mid
february to keep going as fast as we can
in vaccinating all nine mid february if
you add another three weeks to that when
the vaccine
protection really does begin to kick in
you're at the first
week of march and so that's when we will
begin to
first of all open schools and then begin
a
gradual reopening of the economy if we
continue to see good data
and is predicated to your question on
really high quality data of
hospitalization rates coming down we
still have 33 000 people in the hospital
and of course death still remains we are
far too high
and it's a grim uh piece of data but
it does feel though even from the press
conference yesterday that the
case numbers as much as anything else is
going to be one of the metrics the key
metrics that we're using
and you're nodding along but there are
those on your own back benches
who feel that the goal posts have
somewhat been moved originally it was
all about protecting the nhs ensuring
that that was not overly burdened case
numbers of course
if you have cupboard 19 it's certainly
by no means certain that you're going to
end up in hospital
it does feel that that is an additional
barrier to the country coming out of
lockdown
well we'll be able to see much greater
evidence we have two
studies being carried out at the moment
by private by public health england
um one is in uh care home residence it's
the vivaldi study where we're
testing every day because they're in
category one who've been vaccinated
and one with uh healthcare frontline
staff because they're in category two
of the people who've been vaccinated
that's the siren
study that will give us the evidence
of both transmission now we're seeing
really good
evidence from oxford that needs to be
peer reviewed still that transmission
rates for the oxford vaccine
are reduced by two-thirds and of course
protection from serious
um uh illness and and death uh
is almost 100 with the oxford vaccine
very high
with visor for the pfizer biontech
vaccine
as well so we can't yet put a figure
though can we on the number of people
within care homes
workers care home residents that have
actually had the first stores we
we talk about visits we talk about
having been offered
can you just give us a figure on how
many people in england have
have actually had the vaccine and care
homestead so
we've visited over 10 000
care homes uh and we have if offered the
vaccine to all
residents that are eligible there's a
very small
number of residents who currently uh are
infected with covert you have to wait 28
days to revisit
our plan is that we have four visits to
care homes so first visit
is the first dose you return for a
second visit
to if people have been you know have to
wait the 28 days to get the
first dose then this the third visit
second dose
and then a fourth visit for actually
sort of trying to catch anyone who
hasn't
been vaccinated we have offered it to
each and every care home
in the uk by last weekend and of course
the care home uh workers the people who
look after the residents as well
that number is rising uh because they
have options to go
to hospital hubs and to their gps
as well as being vaccinated in the care
home and so
that has been a huge success uh in terms
of
uh delivery and we continue to do the
other categories that's category one
then you've got to go through all the
other categories we're at 90
of over 80s 90 of over 75s
and 50 of over 70s already vaccinated